all right hello everyone my name is Cole
and yeah this is the talk cooking up a
machine learning platform growing pains
and Lessons Learned
um yeah really excited to be here talk
to you all today I guess it's a topic
that's interesting for many people to
Define what exactly we mean with machine
learning platforms
and that's what I want to share with you
today is a more Hands-On direct
experience working with machine learning
Platforms in an organization like
delivery hero but first what is in it
for you today in this talk what do I
want to cover
largely speaking I want to organize the
talk around three main questions which I
will do my best and try and answer for
you
uh the first question quite important
what is a machine learning platform I
think we should all be able to agree on
something there before we can go into
any more detail
also maybe dig into the motivation
behind why we need one in the first
place
and that's kind of the second question
as well is when do you actually need a
machine learning platform or how much
machine learning platform do you need
which also is very important I think we
should always ask ourselves this before
we put too much effort in and finally
how do you actually build one
so really here I can't give perfect
answers I'm not an absolute expert here
but what I can share my experiences my
perspectives the challenges I faced and
the things I've learned along the way as
we try to build our own machine learning
platform and tools within delivery hero
so first of all maybe a bit of
background and context about myself so
you know where I'm coming from
uh my name is Cole I'm working a
delivery hero in the logistics
department and I'm the manager and Tech
lead for our machine learning platform
team
our team still pretty small and Scrappy
we're myself a product manager and five
other great machine learning Engineers
who are working together to solve these
problems and figure out where we're
supposed to be going with all of this in
total we're supporting around 25
different data scientists across the
logistics Department who are spread
around five different teams who work on
various different kind of domains use
cases and models
if you don't know much about delivery
hero you can give a quick introduction
where we're here in Berlin we also have
a call we also have booth at the
conference so you can come by later
Ambush me and ask me any questions you
might have but basically we're a food
delivery and grocery delivery app we
operate all around the world
and so in total within Logistics we have
30 something models running in
production
across all of our markets around the
world in over 50 countries
generally speaking our models I mean
we're working on Logistics so we work
with a lot of structured data classical
machine learning a lot of boosted trees
not so much neural networks and deep
learning and generally I would classify
our use cases in one of two groups one
is the kind of batch or offline
scheduled prediction models and then we
also have the real-time models that are
deployed as like API endpoints as well
and just for a sense of scale
um one of those low latency user-facing
endpoints and models can serve something
like 130 million predictions in a day
with P95 latencies of less than 10
milliseconds to ensure a good user
experience as well
so that's a bit of context uh just so
you know where I'm coming from I'm sure
many of you work in very different
contexts maybe larger scale smaller
scale different types of problems but
yeah this is where I'm coming from at
least
so the first question I want to get into
what is a machine learning platform and
I want to just check what chat GPT has
to say about this and in general it
gives a pretty solid response as we
might expect
but I'd also like to nitpick this a bit
I think this is a very good answer
because it kind of represents the common
understanding of machine learning
platforms but for someone who wants to
actually build and operate one within a
company I think there's some
misconceptions here as well
the first thing I want to highlight is
this statement here a typical machine
learning platform will offer a range of
features such as data preparation
feature engineering model training model
evaluation deployment and monitoring to
me kind of sounds like the platform does
everything so why do we even need data
scientists right obviously that's not
the reality but this is maybe what
people expect from platform you'll do
everything for me
the second point of course some popular
Machining platforms all the big cloud
providers yes this is true these are
popular machine learning platforms but
often what I find is these aren't enough
on their own right for most data
scientists you kind of need to some glue
to fit these things together and to work
with the components that you need to
solve your problems
and the final part isn't a nitpick
actually I think this is a really great
definition I would uh we'll see this
actually multiple times in other slides
it goes into the motivation of why we
need machine learning platforms and in
their words they can be used by data
scientists developers and businesses to
accelerate the development and
deployment of machine learning
applications so to me this is 100
correct the whole point of a platform
right is to make developers lives easier
so um some good things some bad things
so how would I Define it better right
um again I'm not an expert here so I
think what you should do is just go read
up from these authors of team topologies
they have a lot of really great work
defining what it means to be a platform
team in an organization how you should
structure them how you should
collaborate and they also go into quite
a bit of detail about platforms and
platform Engineering in general
uh which I take a lot of inspiration
from
so first what I think Matthew Skelton
here describes is kind of what we want
to avoid if we're building platforms
within a company right and they describe
these kind of Legacy platforms of the
past which were very big massive
monolithic hard to use black box systems
kind of enforce top-down and mandatory
and I think all of us have some
experience working with this type of
platform and generally
we don't like it right we have to do a
lot of hacks and work arounds to make it
actually work for us
but sometimes this is just what happens
right and bad platforms are made with
good intentions nothing wrong with this
but if you are a platform team or you're
looking to build a platform I think it's
something to be aware of
on the other hand when we talk about
what does a good platform look like I
also really like how they describe
things
in essence a good platform is also a
product right a compelling internal
product again to accelerate delivery by
stream aligned or product teams
and I think this really emphasizes the
key thing to take away from this talk
which is if you're building a platform
realize that your platform is a product
and realize that your developers your
data scientists are your users and you
should treat them with the same respect
that you would you're paying customers
right so focus on the developer
experience how do you make things easier
and faster how do you make things so
that they're not slowing your developers
down they're actually speeding them up
and there's a nice uh concept they've
also coined called Dennis viable
platform so it's kind of a play on MVP
of course
um which I think is also a really good
way to think about Platforms in general
so the concept of Fitness viable
platform is a contrast between a thick
platform which is something kind of
Monolithic Black Box hard to hard to
extend and hard to be flexible with
versus a thin platform which is just
enough to solve your problem and to
really like drive this to an extreme in
the in Matthew skelton's own words in
some cases maybe all you need for a
platform is a Wiki page
right and if that's the case then write
your wiki page and be done with it right
Fitness viable platform and iterate from
there so I think just bringing all these
ideas about good product management good
um software development in general
bringing that into your platform teams
is really the key that we want to strive
for
all right so that's my rant about
platform teams and blah blah blah what
about machine learning platforms right
so I'll give a quick definition and to
be fair the definition is quite loose
so for the literal answer of what a
machine learning platform is or what any
platform is it's just a collection of
shared infrastructure libraries tools
documentation processes etc etc so I
think what I want to emphasize here is
not just Tech actually it's the
onboarding the user experience talking
with your users is also important
with the overall goal to enable and
accelerate development deployment
operation of machine learning use cases
at scale
so this combines some of the things
chatgpt said also with team topologies
in general and from my point of view is
a really good way to look at what we're
trying to do
and to give a bit more context of what
we are working on within my team at
Logistics and delivery hero we roughly
divide up our machine learning platform
into three main products visualized here
at a very abstract level so on the top
you have kind of the core of most
machine learning platforms which is your
model orchestration development and
training tools that's where you need to
run your training jobs at scale
instructor dags Etc
once you have a trained model you need
to actually release that somehow that's
the second kind of product on the bottom
right which is all about how do we
deploy and serve the models at scale how
do we also monitor them how do we a B
test and experiment them evaluate how
good they are
and finally the third product line is
about a feature store and in particular
we're focusing on what we call a live
feature store so essentially capturing
data in real time from the rest of our
backend systems and providing tools to
help data scientists Aggregate and serve
that in their models to provide better
quality data for better quality
predictions
so that's a just a little bit of insight
but um that's not really the core of my
talk so if you have more questions about
this feel free to find me later
um
and I want to double down a bit on the
motivation behind this right so so why
do we actually need a separate platform
team why do we actually need to worry so
much about platforms don't we already
have like devops platforms and stuff in
our companies isn't that enough
and to answer this I would also refer to
this really nice Google research article
I think the title kind of says it all if
you haven't read it look into it it's um
it's not too long and has a lot of great
information it's from 2014 but I find
it's still extremely relevant today so
yeah the title is machine learning the
high interest credit card of technical
debt and I think for anyone who's worked
on machine learning or data science at
production scale I hope you agree with
the statement
um technical debt is just hard to avoid
almost impossible to mitigate and it
just can escalate out of control right
and so this is a bit of why we think
about platforms right we want to handle
this and the article talks about a lot
of reasons why this is true a lot of it
um
you know talking about data and a lot of
other things but one aspect that I want
to zero in on is just the tooling
landscape
so if I look around and what tools are
out there to do machine learning
it's ridiculous right I mean it's almost
comical and the cognitive load that the
average data scientist has to deal with
is is enormously high and this was what
results in really things dragging out
and slowing down in a lot of
organizations
so if we think about these three main
streams that I focused on before for our
machine learning platform within each of
these you have a choice to make right
you have all of these great tools out
there some open source are managed you
can build or you can buy and you need
experts to decide which of these tools
actually make sense for us you need to
learn about oh one second
uh
all right
I think we're back
foreign
sorry about that so uh Tech debt tooling
landscape cognitive load right so if you
think about all these tools
um you have to make a decision which
tool are you going to invest in right
also you need to deploy and operate this
somewhere and sometimes you know data
scientists can handle one or two of
these individually it's fine but when
things go wrong who's responsible for it
and do you really have the expertise
that you would like to work with these
tools at scale and this is like a
curation of tools that I personally have
ever used or like researched quite
heavily to see if they make sense for us
the reality is much more Grim this is a
graphic I just found online and it's
kind of comical right like okay if you
want to break into machine learning what
do you do learn all of this good luck
um
so if you know anyone who can do all
this please reach out I think we'd love
to hire them but yeah it's it's this is
why we need platforms right we want to
make this easier and we want to make
sure that data scientists can deliver
value to the business in the end
so when do you actually need a machine
learning platform
given this kind of loose thinnest viable
platform definition I'll cheat here and
say you probably needed one yesterday
um but I would also say this is kind of
the wrong question because if a Wiki
page is a sufficient platform for you
then you already have a platform so
rather I would ask when should you
invest in a better platform right when
should you dedicate more time and
resources to actually figure out how to
build a good platform
and this has of course a lot more Nuance
to it and I think it depends on the
context and your judgment and your
organizations but from my perspective
um the big reasons are one of these so
whenever you're recognized that you're
having problems in your organization
around onboarding new data scientists
maintaining your production
flows and projects and systems you know
keeping things online firefighting
dealing with incidents doing things at
scale over time right if you if you're
continuously face problems with this in
multiple different projects and teams
then it's probably a good sign that uh
you could do with having a better
platform right
and so if you get this far and you're
saying yeah I need a better platform
how should you actually go about it I
think this is really the hardest part to
answer and I I can't really give you all
the answers but I can share at least my
experiences and what I've learned along
the way
and I want to really show
some real Hands-On Journey that we've
gone through at delivery hero but before
I do that
I can give my kind of Snappy platitudes
first uh first Smart Start small and
iterate you know like any good product
you shouldn't lock yourself in a room
and build something over a year and then
expect it to work in the end it's it
usually doesn't pan out so well
second thing listen to your data
scientists which implicitly means talk
to your data scientists I've I've um
I've heard too many stories about
platforms that were developed in a
vacuum uh over the course of one or more
years and then kind of flopped right and
it's not a surprise I mean if you build
something and you think you know exactly
what people need but you didn't actually
ask them and you didn't actually
prototype with them you didn't actually
collaborate with them then you can't
really be surprised when it doesn't work
exactly as you expected it
and in summary treat it like a product
right it is a product it's internal to
your company maybe your users are not
you know paying you dollars but they're
paying you in their time and you know
your data scientists will be a lot
happier if you you know treat them with
the same respect that we do with all our
normal customers
so yeah
um moving on from here I wanted to share
a bit about how this has happened for me
um not my previous company also at
delivery hero and my colleagues the
delivery hero
so yeah I mean I I don't wanna I don't
want to hide anything here I want to be
very honest share with you all our
mistakes as well what we've learned
along the way and the challenges we've
faced
and to do that I want to zero in on this
model orchestration as a specific
component of an Imaging Learning
platform and how that developed over the
years at delivery hero and for many of
this I wasn't there so this is kind of
secondhand information for my colleagues
but uh it's pretty accurate as far as I
can tell
um
at the beginning uh you're kind of like
I think this is pretty common I've had
this experience in multiple places
you're kind of like a startup within a
larger company right this is how a lot
of data science comes to be you've hired
the first two data scientists or ml
engineers and you just kind of say hey
we heard data is good
do something right
um and at this point obviously your Tech
debt you actually have no Tech so you
have no Tech debt you also have no
platform to speak of and so at this
point
you just have to kind of put your head
down and figure out how to get things
done right and at this point it's
definitely too early to think about ml
platforms like you have two head count
they should be spending all of their
time to provide value to the business
right I think that's very clear
and you know we're smart people we're
data professionals engineers and data
scientists Etc eventually we managed to
do it right and eventually we also
figure out oh we have to talk to the
business we have to convince people to
use our model we have to integrate with
other systems uh etc etc etc and
eventually maybe a few iterations down
the line you do it right you you're able
to provide value to the business the
business making more money everyone's
happy
um and at this stage it's quite
interesting because based on my
definition of ml platform there is kind
of the seed of a platform even at this
stage and this is what it looks like in
the first
maybe a couple years at deliver hero
it's a little bit embarrassing but
essentially our entire compute
infrastructure was the two personal
laptops of our first two data scientists
who joined uh one of them would set an
alarm every day to wake up and press a
button to like run the forecast that day
and publish it to production so you can
imagine you know if you spill a beer on
your laptop then production's down for a
week until you get a new one not the
best platform but it is kind of what was
working and what was needed to get to
that first stage right there's nothing
wrong with that
um
but we'll see eventually that reaches
its limit also in terms of documentation
basically none you probably have like a
notepad somewhere in your computer where
you've just copied these like lengthy
commands to make sure you can actually
run things when things Break
um and this is what it really looked
like for us at delivery hero for some
time but of course once you get past
this first hurdle and you've kind of
deployed your first data science model
into production you've provided some
business value then things start to
accelerate very naturally right and
that's where things start to accelerate
you start hiring new people you start
exploring new use cases on the side you
also start to iterate on your existing
use cases probably scale it up quite a
bit in terms of the data features and
complexity of your models and as you do
that this this High interest credit card
of technical debt that you've been
spending so freely in the early stages
starts to kind of
um surface its its head a little bit
and you discover that um or at least we
discovered that
yeah this this old way of doing things
things need to change
but that being said at this stage
um there really is no true platform to
speak of and things emerge quite
naturally and it's quite an exciting
phase to be and things are moving quite
quickly
for us what it looked like was we
figured out okay like running without
Docker and on local machines probably
not the best way to do things we need
some kind of cloud-based infrastructure
so at some point we set up airflow right
and we figure out how to run our dags on
airflow how to set up projects we even
wrote a python framework to kind of
generate airflow dags from like a yaml
file so we could onboard new projects
easily we also started creating some
documentation onboarding guides right
how do you get access to all the tools
which tools to start using when you
first join the company and also just
some shared python libraries and modules
that we could put some like common code
in so that all the projects could share
those we could maintain it a bit easier
right
and already looking back it's kind of
impressive like it was a fully
functioning platform in a sense but
there was no like proper maintainer or
owner of it and I think that's actually
really good because at this point it's
like a user-driven platform right users
creating the platform for themselves and
so it works quite well without even
thinking about it too deeply
um
but
problems do start to grow right I mean
without
take paying too much attention to the
tech debt eventually for us at least
things did eventually I would say get
out of control in particular we hired
more and more data scientists we tried
to tackle more and more different types
of problems and use cases and I think at
some point
um it became quite clear that things
were just not working like they used to
right you know you talk to a data
scientist and you say you know
and you hear them say to you you know
what I don't really know when am I doing
data science anymore right like I'm
spending all my time
I don't know debugging and fixing things
this one country failed the data is
invalid here the data types are broken
there right all these like little
problems that pop up the infrastructure
is not working okay who knows how to
like restart airflow right and these are
the issues that we face over time and at
some point we had to like really figure
out how to improve the situation and I
think as you grow it becomes quite
obvious that the boundaries the
responsibilities aren't clear it doesn't
really make sense for the same data
scientists to maintain all of your
infrastructure and be working full-time
on some specific specific data use cases
and so for us the first step we took
which didn't actually solve anything at
first was to um
re-partition our work a little bit and
this was really the start of a new
development a new a new direction of
things because we had dedicated people
that were set were focusing on like
airflow the infrastructure the python
tooling that we had built
and at this point we didn't call
ourselves a platform team and we really
weren't treating our platform like a
product yet right we were just saying
hey you've been to the company a long
time you know how all of our
infrastructure Works you're pretty good
at it I know you're a data scientist but
how about we call you an email engineer
yet now we shift you one disk to the
right give you a new hat and that'll
solve our problems right
um and eventually it did of course
um you know clarifying responsibility is
very important also the data science
team started to like segment themselves
along specific domains and use cases
but it also took a lot of time to be
clear right to actually get things under
control and pay down this technical debt
and get things stable again and then
also deal with all the constant changes
happening in other parts of the
organization and keep things running
that does also take quite a bit of
effort to be honest but eventually we
were able to achieve that and this is
kind of the era where or the phase where
I actually joined the company I joined
directly into this this ml engineering
functional team at the bottom and so
there was this like subtle transition as
we hired more people and things evolved
like this this team at the bottom became
much more engineering focused we weren't
data scientists who got renamed to
Engineers we were actually Engineers
hired into the company and of course we
had a lot of things to resolve we had to
support a lot of new use cases we had to
do some ad hoc firefighting but of
course we prioritize things and
eventually you figure out how to not
just patch it but to get things in a
pretty healthy and stable state
and once we got to this point I think
this is where really we started to have
a series of small existential crises
where we thought to ourselves what is
our job actually why does our team exist
you know what is our role in the company
and this is what led me to discover all
the things I'm sharing with you today
about how we should think about
platforms right and now we're like
officially rebranded to a platform team
and we're also redefining how we
collaborate with data scientists Etc so
it's an ongoing Journey but this is I
think one of the big turning points
and when we achieved this where we we
figured out how to manage the tech debt
we had some space and some time to pause
and think and prioritize
um some interesting things actually
happened
the elephant in the room for us really
was airflow
um I don't know I guess many of you have
experience with airflow I see some
chuckling but no one really liked
airflow right
but we just kind of accepted that
airflow was our master and we were just
going to serve it forever and data
scientists figured out how to make it
work and we built layers and
abstractions on top of it to try to make
it better
um
but it wasn't really working in many
areas and we start to think okay like
what's going wrong here or or how can we
fix this and how can we make this a more
long-term sustainable platformer product
to give you a bit more background about
how we did things and how we still do
things to be honest
um we have we were using airflow we had
developed this framework we called it
one dag internally where you could
essentially spin up these dags which
would partition across our different
countries and partition your your dags
into concrete steps that are kind of
standardized across all the projects and
so there were some really good things
about it to be fair
for a production stable runs that
weren't changing often it was perfect I
mean just have a thing you have a
dashboard you have a UI it runs and then
when it breaks you go read the logs you
re-trigger It Whatever the yaml
interface was also pretty nice for like
onboarding new people you didn't have to
learn all of this airflow magic and
operators we could have data scientists
just kind of use airflow rather than
having to operate it
but I think the biggest thing that it
didn't solve for us was the development
and prototyping which is kind of the
most important thing that a data
scientist should be doing
um also it was quite rigid and
restrictive so whenever like the
projects would scale or the use cases
would change people really had
challenges to say or they would come to
us with requests like oh can we do this
in airflow and we're like ah maybe but
like we'd have to like really figure
that out and keep it backwards
compatible and it became very difficult
to kind of keep up with all the changing
requirements
and so what do we do
um
we kind of took a step back and we
thought about okay if airflow isn't it
for us what else is there out there
right what can we look at instead
and we did a survey of the landscape we
looked at a lot of tools in in some
detail and trying to figure out what
could work for us
we did look at kubeflow I think it's the
most obvious choice if you look around
the Internet it's like the reigning open
source Champion
um and at first it was like wow this is
like amazing like we've been used to
airflow we had our own abstractions to
like move data between tasks and now
like kubeflow you can just do it and it
works
um but somehow it didn't work for us
like we just tried to re-implement our
airflow use case in kubeflow and then
like we just found some GitHub issues
where they said yeah sorry the DSL
doesn't support it better luck next time
right
um so we were a bit worried that we
would get locked into this rigid DSL
that really didn't solve our use case
and would again lead to the same problem
we had with airflow so far
we also thought to ourselves well maybe
maybe airflow is not the problem maybe
we're the problem right maybe airflow
actually is a good tool we just need to
learn how to use it and we did a little
bit of research here
um I mean to be honest I think we all
lacked a bit of motivation to do this
properly but
there were cool features of airflow had
that did seem like they would solve real
problems we were facing but all the time
it felt like it was very difficult to
make it adapt it and make it usable for
our data scientists right it would
really take a lot of work to to package
all of this in a way and make it usable
whereas we look at these other open
source Frameworks and it seems like
they've solved these problems from the
jump right
Daxter was a pretty cool one I think
what I learned from Daxter is like how
important local development is
um they have a really nice way to just
spin everything up locally run purely on
local and then you can later report that
to the cloud but it didn't really work
with like containers and Docker images
the way we might expect and we had a lot
of Legacy stuff flying around so we were
a bit afraid to kind of completely scrap
everything we had and start from scratch
um Argo workflows was our kind of
reigning Champion for a while we
actually are still using it to some
degree if you don't know Argo workflows
is the backbone to kubeflow and um
surprise surprise it's a lot more
powerful but it requires a lot more work
to actually use
um so but we could Port over our airflow
stuff into into Argo workflows pretty
transparently and actually have it kind
of backwards compatible for a while
and the main limitation we found with
Argo workflows was that you have to do
everything in this kubernetes native
yaml way
um and you know you have templated yaml
you have for loops and if blocks and
this and that within yaml blocks
and I mean I had some people in my team
who could manage that I sat down for a
day and I just had so many bugs and
weird error messages I couldn't figure
out and I was pretty confident we can't
give this to data scientists right like
we would have to maintain the yaml
templates for them if they had a
question again they would have to come
to us to extend and adapt them to their
needs
and so how did we get out of this kind
of
confusing situation how do we decide
where we go next I think there was three
like main factors that came together for
us the first thing I want to emphasize
again we talked to our data scientists
and what do we learn from talking to
them I think at one point I interviewed
10 different data scientists within the
span of a week or two and I got 10
different answers about how they
actually do their development not only
like process wise but also which tools
they use which infrastructure they use
we had people launching like custom Coop
jobs because the airflow was too rigid
um you know different types of
Frameworks to visualize and understand
the results it was just a chaotic mess
and it all made sense at the local scale
right everyone was Finding workarounds
to their problems and no one was doing
anything wrong but it just really proved
that our tooling was not solving their
needs otherwise they would be using it
and so in summary like prototyping
development needed to be a lot easier
onboarding and understanding the system
needed to be a lot easier and also just
in terms of scaling and dealing with
these larger and larger amounts of data
and complex models needed to be able to
be handled in a more in a more flexible
way
the second thing that happened was
metaflow announced native like
kubernetes native support for Argo
workflows
and after hearing about this and reading
the docs a bit it really like everything
somehow clicked like we had been like
fighting with tools for so long and we
kind of skipped metaflow because it was
at first only in some AWS managed
fashion and we weren't really excited to
like figure out all of that Tech and how
it works um you know we're pretty
kubernetes Centric and in our deployment
so far
and Argo workflows we also were pretty
confident about we've been using it
actually at scale and we we trusted the
tech and we also trusted that we could
kind of understand and invest more to to
become more experienced with it but most
importantly meta flow solved a lot of
the problems that we were having when we
tried to use Argo workflows directly so
metaflow allowed you to really do purely
local development have a really clean
python DSL to create and generate your
dags to easily transition with a few CLI
arguments from local development to like
cluster like kubernetes development and
also use Argo for your scheduling needs
Etc and so we really became convinced
that um
if we did it properly that meta flow
could be the right tool for us and
finally we we took a closer look at our
priorities so I think especially the
early days of exploring Argo and
kubeflow we always kind of did things
half half we were thinking okay we have
this like airflow system that we can't
really get out of and so we tried to
find okay can we find a development tool
that can kind of complement airflow but
that necessarily puts you in a position
where you're like dealing with the worst
of Both Worlds
and so finally we kind of decided you
know if we can find a better tool then
why not make that the tool of choice
right it's not going to be easy of
course and I'll get into that in a
second but this is ultimately the
decision we came to that we we should
aim higher you know that's one of our
values at our company we should also not
just focus on incremental improvements
or you know adding new things to help
solve the problem we should also figure
out what's the Legacy stuff that we want
to deprecate right what's the stuff
that's creating too many support
requests and creating too much friction
for our users that's actually worth
spending the time to to eliminate or or
migrate away from
and with all this in mind so this is
what the decision we made in the end we
we did some pilots and prototypes with
metaflow we got great feedback from the
first early adopters of it in our
company and now we're in the process of
actually figuring out how to make this
the tool of choice we still have stuff
running on airflow we still have stuff
running on Argo workflows
um so it's still a bit of a mess and
it's still a learning process but that's
where We've Ended up now and
that's I think kind of the closing point
I want to highlight here so I don't want
to I don't want you to take away that
meta flow is the answer to all your
problems right it definitely isn't
everyone has their own context and
situation for us meta flow seems really
great so far but it also opens up a
whole host of new problems and to be
honest it makes a lot more work for us
in the beginning right but we commit to
it of course with this long-term vision
in mind
so always keep that in mind right I mean
Legacy projects and migrating them
that's always going to be a pain also
just convincing people that this is the
right choice to make right
and you know some people there they've
gotten so used to airflow in our company
that moving them away from it despite
how much they might hate airflow is
still going to be difficult right they
have to unlearn certain patterns that
they've developed over years and they
have to figure out how to adapt and we
also have to figure out how to develop
new tools on top of metaflow that
actually fit their needs properly so
yeah it's it's not an easy path uh being
a platform team in summary but I think
it's very worthwhile and very
fascinating to figure out how to make
this stuff work better for your data
scientists and help your company achieve
much more on the whole
that's all thank you everyone
um again I have a I think we have some
time for questions but I'll also be here
all day you can Ambush me and and find
me if you want to talk about any stuff
in more detail that I didn't cover in
the talk today I'm super happy to meet
anyone else here who's working on ML
platforms or email engineering or data
science at scale
thank you
uh thank you call for the amazing talk
uh we have time five or ten minutes for
questions uh here's the first one
thank you for the talk first of all I'm
curious you mentioned once as a side
note that you um I think you we really
find how we collaborate with the data
scientists I'm really curious about like
the reasoning behind it and the old and
the new workflow
sorry could you repeat sure you once
said we redefined how we collaborate
with the data scientists as a platform
team
then you basically scratched that and
came up with a new processing I'm really
curious about that yeah so I think at
the beginning because we have to
remember at the beginning we were one
kind of cohesive team and then we just
kind of split the two chunks and so the
boundaries weren't very clear and so
what we kind of naturally became was
more of a support
team right an infrastructure team where
we were dealing with ad hoc problems
also help Implement some like Greenfield
use cases from scratch and what we're
trying to currently redefine ourselves
as is more of a platform team uh focus
more on like self-service and
documentation and really Empower data
scientists to do things on their own
rather than having them forcing them to
come to us with problems and then wait
for us to solve them for them right so I
think this is like the core of how we
want to change the collaboration model
between the teams so that each team is
like as independent as possible and has
its own kind of vision and like goals in
mind as well
cool
yes
thanks for the doc
my main question is about your relation
your team related to other teams you you
set up this uh this platform you're
using some kind of infrastructure did
you set up everything from scratch is
there a data engineering team or an
infrastructure team that yes very good
question yeah it's a complex landscape
and it's always evolving we have always
had a very strong we call it a
foundation team they manage all of the
kubernetes Clusters and core
infrastructure terraform Helm all this
kind of stuff so we build on top of what
they have but what we need to do for
data science is very different from what
they usually provide so we often have to
kind of build another layer on top of
this we also have a pretty strong data
um
data's platforms within delivery hero
especially for data warehousing and data
curations what we call it and for a
while actually currently these data
teams actually do manage the airflow
infrastructure
but now with metaflow we've become the
the infrastructure team for metaflow
which is also an interesting change it's
a lot more work of course right you have
to think about these kind of challenges
as well
okay thanks there's a small follow-up
question yeah um so the the
um what kind of skills do you as ml
Engineers now need that you didn't need
as data scientists and what kind of
skills did you do you not use anymore
from compared to data scientists yeah so
I think email engineering right you
always have like platform teams you also
can have embedded email engineers and I
think those are quite different roles in
the end and I I've yeah a lot of people
I think struggle to figure out how to
define these for us like as a platform
team there's a lot more infrastructure
work to be very clear right especially
at the beginning of these projects
um so we need to know a lot more about
kubernetes right and to know a lot more
about terraform and Helm and all of
these core Technologies in the cloud
providers right and try to make that as
easy as possible for data scientists to
get into and yeah we're naturally a bit
further away from the actual direct
modeling and the business cases that go
launch into production right we're still
collaborate and pair up very closely
with data scientists when they have
issues and to help them unblock them
right but uh you know we're not every
day sitting down with psychic learn and
figuring out uh how to make these
features and this models work for these
specific business cases anymore
thank you
hi aren't you afraid of linking your
software your data science teams are
writing with the infrastructure by doing
these type of code annotations and
things
because now it look how metaflow looks
to me is like now you're injecting
infrastructure into the code and now
you're linking it yeah yeah and don't
you want to have this flexible so aren't
you afraid of having this because now
you're
you're dependent on metaflow yeah yeah
this was like one of our hesitations for
sure
um because with airflow we had several
layers right but the problem with
airflow is that the daglogic was here
and your project logic was here
and so there was never a way if you
wanted to make a change to one or the
other like it just became very messy and
with metaflow we can combine that all
into one repository still I think it
makes sense to you know the the metaflow
files should Define the dags and the
infrastructure and then your actual like
business logic should be separated into
separate python files right this is like
a best practice that we would recommend
um but it does mean there is room for
like some more messy and uh messy stuff
but it's a trade-off right for us I
think we've learned that data scientists
need flexibility
um especially in how they structure
their dags right so for us to scale some
projects they need to train at Country
level City level Zone level this and
that right and we can't possibly think
of every single use case they might have
and provide that as a yaml config
somewhere right it's just not an
efficient way to work so what we're
aiming to do is give them the power over
the infrastructure and provide as much
support and abstraction so that they
don't you know break things of course
but that's the trade-off yeah it's it's
not an easy choice and we we thought
about it a lot we had a lot of
discussions on this exact topic so
yeah that's where we stand on it um we
think it's useful and from our
experience so far but you know there are
some downsides definitely
right great talk thanks how do you
handle deployments to Productions or in
other words who will be called on the
weekend when there is a problem on prod
is it your team or the data scientist
yes this has been like a running joke
almost
um we every couple of months we talk
about on-call teams um
so luckily in delivery hero we have this
definition of tier one two three and
four services and we've designed and
generally all of our data science
production models to be in the tier
three category so we always have other
systems in place that are proper
software engineering maintained systems
with on-call Engineers which can fall
back gracefully if the data science
models are broken
so for that reason we don't have
dedicated on-call for like weekends and
stuff like this for data science or for
our platform team so we can we can
handle some downtime
um but it this was the problem in the
old setup where we kind of felt
responsible for all of the helm
deployments and kubernetes deployments
so when things did break we kind of got
looped in somehow and it really felt
like we should be an on-call team but we
weren't was a bit which was a bit
confusing now the direction is uh we're
actually moving also the data science
into more cross-functional teams so they
will have dedicated software Engineers
as well which would be much better
suited to be on call because for us I
mean we have maybe three Engineers
maintaining 10 different model Services
it's just not it's not feasible right so
our direction is more that the data
science team should own their systems
end to end also ideally be
cross-functional and have their own
on-call if needed
um last question
what is the reason why you're not
considering Cloud native tools such as
Amazon sagemaker
um it's a good question I think
one reason big reason is actually cost
so we run our own kubernetes clusters on
spot and it's just orders of magnitude
cheaper than um paying for like even
vertex AI or or sagemaker another reason
is just like all of these Cloud
Solutions at least from my experience
you usually need to kind of build
another abstraction on top of it to make
it fit with the rest of your your
systems and tools and so for us there's
really no strong benefit to use it like
we might pick and choose a few things
here and there but in general we're much
happier with uh running the running our
own code and our own Docker images on
kubernetes like it's much more I guess
flexible and we can adapt it to our
needs as we as we want
well that's all
um thank you very much for the questions
and call again thanks for your talk
thanks everyone